and the dragon was wroth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed
which keep the commandments of god and
have the testimony of jesus christ
but who make up this remnant
join the word inspired sabbath november
27th at 2 o'clock p.m eastern standard
time for a q a with elder randy skeet on
the remnant church
other special guests include jonathan
david archie kevin gomez and karissa
hunt
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this meeting will be hosted on zoom and
live stream to denisha mccurchion's
youtube channel personal and the word
inspired facebook pages and twitch
profile at the word inspired
links are in the description of this
video feel free to like share and
subscribe
we hope to see you there and welcome
your prayers and support as we finish
the work of the gospel thank you and god
bless
all right let us pray
dear heavenly father we come before you
with a grateful heart sing thank you so
much for your kindness and your grace
and your mercies we thank you for your
truth and for your holy spirit
we ask lord that you forgive us of our
sins and speak to and through us dear
lord especially anoint your manservant
elder randy skeet put your words in his
mouth let his mind even be so in tune
with yours that the thoughts he thinks
come straight from you and that his
words would be straight from your throne
be with those of us that are listening
and taking part in participating we ask
that you guide and direct us and prepare
our hearts to receive your word and to
apply it to our lives in jesus name we
pray
amen amen
joined with us today is international
speaker elder randy skeet he is a
husband and a humble man of god and in
addition to
studying at oakwood university he also
attended the seventh-day theological
seminary at andrews university for the
ministry he has traveled the world near
and far
high and low spreading the gospel of the
kingdom and we thank god that elder
skeet has made the time to be with us
today so that we can talk about the
remnant church please welcome elder
randy feet
thank you very much my dear sister god
bless you once again i am delighted to
be a part of this program
which uh i'm sure has been and will
continue to be
a blessing to all those who tune in
answering bible questions is a vital
part of the leadership of the church as
a service to the membership it does not
remove the responsibility of the members
to study because god will teach you
individually but there comes a time when
it is appropriate for our members to ask
this question or that question and this
program i believe serves that end
answering questions for the people of
god and so i'm ready to answer the
questions as they come and my prayer is
that the spirit of god will direct my
thinking and my speaking so that truth
is well represented because jesus christ
himself is truth by the way so is the
father deuteronomy 32 4 and so is the
holy spirit first john 5 6 and christ of
course is truth john 14 6 i'll try to
lift up truth i'm ready for the
questions
amen all right
our first question is who composes the
remnant church
is it only seven day adventists
who are or rather what are the defining
characteristics of the remnant and what
is its purpose
let's get a broad view of what remnant
might mean in isaiah chapter 1 verse 2
isaiah says hear o heavens and give here
o earth for the lord have spoken
i have nourished and brought up children
and they have rebelled against me the ox
know his honor and he asks his master
scribble
but israel does not know
my people does not consider
ah sinful nation
a people laden with iniquity a seed of
evil doers children like corrupters
they're forsaken the lord they provoke
the holy one of israel they've gone away
backward now isaac is describing the
spiritual condition of the israelites
sinful nation a people living with
iniquity a seed of evil doers children
that are corrupters
from the soul of the foot even unto the
head there's no soundness in it but
wombs and bruises and putrefying source
that's how he describes israel this is
god telling him to use these words
in verse nine the situation is so dire
in verse nine the bible says except the
lord of hosts had left unto us a very
small remnant
we should have been a sodom and we
should have been as gamora in other
words there was a small group that did
not fit the description in verse four as
sinful nation of people laden with
iniquity a seed of evildoers children
that are corrupters there was a small
group who lived differently they were
faithful to god and so and they
preserved by the power of god and their
cooperation of course and so the bible
says except the lord of hosts had left
unto us a very small remember let's
continue the chapter to understand where
the remnant or how the remnant fits
verse 15 when you spread forth your
hands i will hide my eyes from you yea
when you make many prayers i will not
hear your hands are full of blood wash
you make you clean put away the evil of
your doing from before mine eyes cease
to do evil verses 15 16 and verse 17
learn to do well seek judgment relieve
the oppressed judge the fatherless plead
for the widow do what is right clearly
then the remnant in verse 9 refers to
that small group that was doing what is
right in the sight of god as outlined in
his holy word and so the remnant from
the advertised perspective which is a
biblical one the remnant refers to that
small group
less that is still faithful to thus set
the lord and with respect to these last
years we're talking about the three
angels messages and all that that
expression encompasses the remnant that
small group still clinging to the faith
which was once delivered unto the saints
amen and so revelation 12 17 tells us
and the dragon was wrapped with a woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed which keep the commandments of
god and the testimony of jesus christ
now in verse chapter 13 of revelation i
stood up sand in the sea and saw a beast
rise up out of the sea the dragon now
seems to be looking for the two uh
agents which he will use the sea beasts
of revelation 13 1 through 10 and the
two horned beasts revelation 13 11
through 18. the dragon and those two
will combine to try to overthrow the
retina not the entire bolt of cloth just
the remnant because it is the remnant as
in the case of the days of isaiah isaiah
1 9 there were a few who were not
described as sinful nation laid with
iniquity cedarville evil doers children
that are corrupted the small remnant
holding on to god's messages as
entrusted to them
are what we understand as the remnant
today now that question has several
parts what's the second part of it
okay so the second part was is it only
seventh day adventist which i think
you've covered
okay but let me let me deal with that
directly the remnant is described in
revelation 12 revelation 14 revelation
12 17 and the dragon was wrath with the
woman and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
commandments of god and the testimony of
jesus christ so we have those two
defining characteristics we add to that
revelation 14 verse 12 because this is
also an end time because the the the
right after that is the coming of christ
in revelation 14. so we're dealing with
the end time people here is the patience
of the saints they are they that keep
the commandments of god and the faith of
jesus and so we have the commandments of
god the testimony of jesus the faith of
jesus these are the distinguishing marks
of the remnant people of god and
remember there are a small group from a
larger whole
now are they only seven of the averages
i cannot come boldly and say they are
only 7. i will say the remnant i
describe that those who keep the
commandments of god that have the
testimony of jesus christ and the faith
of jesus christ those are the ones that
are counted as the remnant but i must
add according to john 10 16 other sheep
i have which are not of this fold
they are in babylon that is the god
that's the target group for the loud try
of revelation 18 1-5 come out to her my
people god has people in babylon now
they're not keeping the commandments
they're disobedient ignorantly so they
need to be informed that they may now
practice remnant behavior and so in a
certain sense they are
those who are god wants to bring into
the remnant there are some preachers who
say the remnant refers to the visible
and the invisible when i pick no large
quarrel with them what i'm saying is the
remnant is described as those who keep
the commandments of god have the
testimony of jesus and the faith of
jesus we cannot say that those in
babylon are doing that even though god
sees in the heart of those persons is a
desire for truth so they are called out
that they may come and be a part of the
remnant and so the remnant are those
described in revelation 12 17 14 12 but
god has others who have a heart for the
teachings of the remnant and he will
call them and they will come because my
sheep know my voice
amen amen see the world is divided into
obedient
those who obey and those who don't
now
so it's not dividing between advocates
and non-advertisers is divided between
those who obey and those who don't
there's some who obey actively there's
some who have a heart to obey they just
don't have the knowledge and they need
to be given that knowledge through the
loud cry
which should be energized by the latter
rain by the way
but those who make that loud cry will be
those who are using the former rain
where those using the early rain using
the former rain will be the ones who
will receive the latter and to give that
loud cry it has to be loud because the
noise of false ever in babylon is so
loud that the loud pride has to out loud
the largeness of babylon and so it's a
loud cry that people can hear
for instance if you look down to history
all the reformers virtually all identify
the papacy as a little horn the man of
sin the sea beast all of them virtually
yet it does not seem to sink in so we
need a loud loud to crash through the
high decibels of error that are causing
people to go off in all kinds of
directions it has to be loud and those
in the heart for the remnant will come
amen amen and you know ellis i believe
that's a perfect segue into our next
question which speaks to the purpose of
the remnant why we are here
this question is what is the
relationship between the remnant and the
three angels messages excellent question
if you look at revelation uh revelation
14 has the final message for the world
verse 6-12 of course revelation 18 1-5
is uh is an amplification of the third
angel's message now
after revelation 14 6-12 or down to 13
we have the coming of christ as
represented by
christ sitting on a horse having a
sickle in his hand and a crown on his
head
which means that this the messages of
revelation 14 6-12 are very very
critical they are the messages that
prepare the world to receive christ he
must come back now if you look at the
last part of revelation 14
from verse 14 on we have two harvests
and both are right it is the preaching
of the three angels messages that brings
the world to the point of rightness
either for christ or against him either
way this is the state the world must
reach before jesus come because christ
will not come and put in the sickle
except the harvest is right joel chapter
3 verse 13 put you in the circle for the
harvest is right mark 4 28 29 when the
harvest is come immediately he put it in
the sickle and so the messages of
revelation 14 6-12 are designed to ripen
the harvest one way or the other
and the remnant are called
to deliver that message boldly even at
the loss of life the same way they
overcame him by the blood of the lamb by
the word of the testimony and they love
not their lives unto the death
revelation 14 11 the remnant must have
that same attitude we don't care about
our lives we're not reckless but our
lives are not our most precious
possession our precious possession is
truth as it is in jesus the remnant has
been raised up to declare the end time
messages of revelation 14 6-12 which no
other church on the face of the earth
does not even attempt to deliver
that's the purpose of the remnant not
only to preach it but to live it
so the living of it gives power to the
preaching of it
amen amen so we have a work to do as
god's people to give that loud cry
and you know in i was listening to an
another another lecture on the remnant
church and we also seen revelation
chapter 10
how god literally raised up a people to
declare
to declare the three angels messages to
the world
and that's clearly stated in the last
verse of revelation 10 that was
prophesied again before people nations
kindreds and counts
the prophet saying must go on it did not
end
with uh 1844 has to go on
and it will crescendo in an outcry when
that is preached that's when christ will
come
after that is preached
probation closes the plagues fall christ
comes back
amen amen
so we gotta we gotta work we gotta work
we have to give that loud cry so that
people can come out of babylon
and they can work
priority in our lives i cannot stress
this enough you know titus 1 verse 16
says they profess that they know god but
in works they deny him
we are we are experts at giving god lip
service but when the rubber hits the
road we are nowhere to be found the
the the preaching of the gospel must
become a priority for us we must find
ways to do it on the job in the streets
wherever it must be this all-consuming
priority so that christ can come back
it's not just we need to do it in words
we need to actually commit our lives to
it and do it even if it means loss of
life it has to be a priority with no
challenge from any other concern
um amen that thought comes to mind the
preaching of the gospel is a practical
priority for god's people
amen
all right
so i'm turning it over now to brother
jonathan to ask the next three questions
happy sabbath everyone and happy sabbath
elder skeet have you said with my
handsome brother god bless you
you're handsome as well god created oh
thank you thank you i'm surprised thanks
all right so we have a third question
that's actually taken from revelation
chapter 14 verse 5. i'll read it first
it says in their mouth was found no
guile
and also it says for they are without
fault before the throne of god
revelation 14 verse 5 tells us that the
144 000 are found without fault before
the throne of god by what means are they
without fault and did they ever sin
of course they sinned the only person
who never sinned is jesus christ of
course they sin but they conquered sin
the sacrifice of christ which includes
his life his very difficult life his
death his resurrection all of that must
be regarded as a sacrifice of christ the
atonement of christ all of that provides
the power for us to live above sin we
can conquer sin you see i can do all
things through christ the power to
conquer sin is in christ's atonement
with sometimes referred to as his blood
that is the power and so we are required
to come to sin if you study the seven
letters to the seven churches of
revelation chapters two and three
each one is told to overcome
even the two churches that receive no
rebuild smyrna church number two and
philadelphia church number six they
receive no rebuke from christ yet
they're told he that overcometh shall
not be heard of the second death as as
christ told the second year smyrna and
so overcoming overcoming revelation 3 21
to him that overcometh will i grant to
sit with me in my throne even as i also
overcame we must overcome sin the way
christ was victorious yes they have
overcome sin but they have not lived
sinless lives only christ did that but
we have available to us through the
living christ the power to conquer sin
and those persons have conquered saying
and that the final generation on this
earth when jesus christ come will have
conquered saints so that christ can
present them or god the father can
present them to the universe to finally
disprove the charge of satan that god's
law cannot be perfectly kept jesus did
it but he was only one witness and the
jewish tradition says you need two or
three witnesses the final generation
those who conquer sin in the power of
christ will be the second witness god
needs here is christ and here are those
who live a christ-like life and so that
that group in revelation 14 5 they have
conquered sin through christ
and that challenge is for us
everyone who comes to christ that
person's aim must be christ's likeness
total conquest of sin because one sin
unattended will destroy you
the smallest sin the least
so-called significant bad habit will
destroy a person if it is not dealt with
one sinful admitted garden one sin can
ruin things in heaven and so conquest of
sin is absolutely necessary and there
will be those alive on the earth who
have conquered sin through christ they
overcame him by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of the testimony
revelation 12 11. you have conquered sin
amen amen and one of the
connect on to that is also in jude 1 24
it says now
that is able to keep you from falling to
present you faultless
before the presence of his glory with
exceeding joy absolutely yes
it is it must be a personal desire of
ours
it does not happen by osmosis it must be
a person you know jesus said blessed are
they which do hunger and thirst after
righteousness
is the opposite of sin
and so we must hunger and thirst for
this character of christ which is
flawless righteousness
it is possible through him
because it is he living out that life in
us
amen amen
thanks for that answer and so now the
second question
actually ties in with the third question
and we're actually going to be looking
back in revelation chapter 14 on the
verse right before verse 4 which i'll
read
these are they which were not defiled
with women for they are virgins these
are they which follow the lamb with or
so ever he goeth these were redeemed
from among men being the first fruits
unto god and to the land
the second question right here is first
what is meant by the hundred and forty
four thousand not
the filed with woman me
being virgins
not defiled with women simply means
there is no illicit union no illicit
association between error and truth if
you read revelation 17 verse 2 with whom
the kings of the earth have committed
fornication revelation 18 verse 3
says something very similar
fornication spiritually means illicit
union between truth and error which
amounts to the entire thing being
corrupt and so
the 144 000 have kept themselves
theologically pure doctrinally pure in
other words they have been faithful to
thus set the lord jesus said man shall
not live by bread alone but by every
word and eloise explains clearly every
word he meant every commandment which is
the standard of righteousness and if you
study uh christ's responses to the
temptations all three they all come from
a section of deuteronomy that deal with
the that deals with the 10th commandment
only 5-11 christ's responses come from
deuteronomy 6 and deuteronomy 8 the
section that deals with the ten
commandments and so you can understand
the correctness of the lord's statement
when he said man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word he was referring
to the every word being the ten
commandments and frequently in the bible
you'll see commandments and word used
next to each other as parallel
statements because frequently a
commandment is word and word is
commandment and so
the
the 144 000 they have not involved
themselves with a system that is based
on violating the law of god because the
law of god is the standard of
righteousness every doctrine every
theory every profession must be tested
by the law of god they are faithful to
god's law which is another way of saying
they are faithfulness it's christ and
his righteousness
so they're not defiled
with women mean false churches
because we see the women in revelation
uh 17 verse five and upon her head was a
crown was the name written mystery
babylon the great the mother of harlots
and abominations of the earth so there's
babylon and all the harlots the
daughters they're the same same genetic
strain they have different names but
same thing they're opposed to the law of
god
let me just digress briefly hopefully
helpfully
the law of god is really the test of
truth
a man will go and risk his life on the
the war zone to provide medical care he
will do whatever or she asks that person
obey god's law the person will say no
if no
oh yes but only nine the law of god is
absolutely detested correct doctrine
that's why it's the law unto the
testimony if they speak not according to
this word it is because there is no
light and so 144 000 are faithful to
god's truth
and all his commandments are truths
they're not mingled with error that is
what fornication they means are mingled
with women they're virgins they've lived
a doctrinally pure life they have
followed thus the lord and nothing else
and just as god he separated the light
from the darkness
also have to be separated from this
world
communion with with you know how
community has light with darkness and
righteousness and unrighteousness that
doesn't work they've got to be separated
very good thanks for that so now the
final question is revelation 14 verse 4
calls the 144 000 the first fruit unto
god into the land
what is it by the first group
the first verse was the second ceremony
of the seven feasts the israelites had
to celebrate
uh beginning with um
the feast of pentecost not pentecost um
we symbolize the death of christ the
word is left the passover that was the
first one the last one was the feast of
tabernacles right after the day after
passover the feast of unleavened bread
began and
feast the first fruit began the third
day after passover which is the third
day after the resurrect the crucifixion
of christ it was the waving of the very
first uh part of the harvest if you
planted barley or wheat whatever the
first of that to ripen was reaped and
taken to the priest and the priest waved
it to god for god to accept it meaning
that the larger heartless will also be
acceptable to him that's why christ and
those who end up with him are the first
fruits of the larger resurrection to
come and so the hundred and forty four
thousand are called the first fruits
because they're special to god they are
ahead of the larger you know the hundred
forty four thousand would be close to
god than anybody else they would have
gone through trials and tribulations
that no one else will go through because
they'll be living in a time when
there'll be trouble such as the world
has never seen and so they have that
first fruit status
which is
that which precedes the general harvest
and um they'll be alive when jesus
christ comes so in that sense
they see him
ahead of the righteous dead who will
come up
amen the first fruit is the status
amen christ is the first fruits christ
personifies the first fruits first
corinthians 15 20 21 22 144 000 along
with christ even as christ took some
people with him when he rose 144 000 at
the end of time is sort of a larger
fulfillment of that group
amen and also first fruits
for those that also as elvaski was
mentioning about the feast and passover
and you know feast of tabernacles that's
in leviticus chapter 23 for all those
that's right
thank you
all seven feasts are in that chapter all
seven yes
praise god by the way the first fruits
also symbolize the resurrection of
christ because the first fruit the first
fruits were waved the third day after
pentecost you had not been called keep
saying pentecost passover you had
passover the 14th day you have feast of
11 bread begins the next day the 15th
and then that there was considered the
holy sabbath a ceremonial sabbath and
the day after that
was the waving of the first fruits and
so it symbolizes the resurrection of
christ on the third day the first
fruitful wave on the third day
that's why paul says christ rose the
third day according to the scriptures in
first corinthians 58 and that's where we
go to answer that question according to
the scriptures where is that the bible
teaches that christ will rise the third
day which you've got to study to uncover
that bible truth
and the key elements are in leviticus
23.
amen
thank you for that elder squeak and that
passed the baton back to sister denise
mccurchion all right
thank you so much for the jonathan for
posing those questions adding commentary
and elder skeet as usual many thanks for
letting the lord use you to answer those
last three questions
so we've been discussing uh the first
fruits you said that the fursuits have a
distinct experience in that they're
going to go through a time of trouble
such as never was
so their status will be you know it's a
status that is different distinct from
the other righteous dead
now we know from revelation chapter 12
verse 17 that the dragon who is the
devil makes war with this remnant
how does the dragon make war with god's
people is it a physical war
it is not a physical war the war in
heaven which the devil originated was
not necessarily a physical war
it is a war of the mind
the devil attacked this
god says thus said the lord
that here we receive it we reject we
don't accept it in the fist or the knee
or the toes we accept it in the mind so
the war is on the mind
through error and the weapon is error it
was error in heaven deception it was
error in eden when he fell and adam fell
consciously it was it has been errored
down through the ages the devil has
realized violence does not work when he
tried to persecute the church in a few
centuries after christ died the saying
arose the saying was the blood of the
martyrs is the seed of the church the
more he persecuted the church the church
grew what did he do he decided to drop
that that that approach not entirely but
generally and he chose deception
amalgamation now he mingled truth and
error and it worked beautifully so
people are destroyed pleasantly they're
not destroyed violently but the
destruction is the same
because spiritual destruction is worse
than physical destruction the devil uses
error and he uses religious entities to
promote that error which makes it so
deadly because no one would expect an
error to come from a church but the
devil uses a religious entity to spread
his error and his two basic errors are
the dead are not really dead and
sunday's the sabbath
the two fundamental errors with which he
has deceived the whole world revelation
12 verse nine
and so he makes war through twisting
truth we need to understand that
twisting truth and he did not twist
every expression of truth he just needs
to twist a central element of truth
which is the law of god and in that law
the seventh day south
so a law will be passed we know the
sunday law making sunday the legal day
of worship that's coming there's no law
past saying you know don't bear false
witness there's no law that we'll say
legally and i shall not whatever no
their law will be classed
will be passed
and making sabbath observance illegal
and sunday observance but this happened
hundreds of years ago all the way back
to the council of laodicea when sabbath
keeping was outlawed but it will really
be worldwide it will have thief to it
there will be a death penalty
and so the devil makes war by tampering
with truth by tampering with the word of
god that's why you and i need to know
the word of god
and god has guaranteed us if any man
will do his will he shall know the
doctrine john 7 17 a desire to follow
god is essential to understand what
god's word says so the devil's warfare
is
twisting the truth it is the most
effective method of corrupting god's
people twisting the truth
when he came to christ temptation number
one attempt number two jump off the
temple he's therefore it is written he
shall give his angels charge over thee
but he did not say to keep thee in all
thy ways he did not say that but he so
he used the word cleverly not too clever
for christ because christ saw through
his rubbish and so the devil uses the
word he twisted slightly he doesn't tell
you don't go to church he tells you you
know observe this day and if you go on
the saturday he tells you don't do that
don't do that he finds at least one
thing to twist you or to trust me
thereby winning his victory but if we
cling to thus set the lord the devil
cannot overcome us
if you read matthew 8 16 and when the
evil was come they brought unto him many
that were possessed with devils and he
cast out the spirits with his word as it
worked then
it worked before it will work now our
defense is the word and the devil's
target is the word
so we must know the lord
amen amen and sanctify them through thy
truth thy
word that's right
and we see from before that the defining
characteristics of the remnant of god's
last eight people are those that keep
the commandments of god have the
testimony of jesus
and what the devil does is he tries to
strip us of that characteristic which is
why it's so important for us to get to
know god on an intimate level
his word through his word
all right so we already covered the the
second part to this question was by what
means do they overcome the devil we see
that see that in revelation 12 verse 11
that's right
which we covered before
by the word of the word of the lamb by
the the blood of the lamb by the word of
their testimony
now let me comment on the blood of the
lamb
the bible frequently refers to the blood
of christ
we know from leviticus 17 11 the life is
in the blood
the blood carries the life is the blood
is a carrier of the life
now when christ was in gethsemane he
shed blood but that wasn't a payment to
sin are you following me because if he
changed his mind and gone back
we would still be lost so he shed blood
in gethsemane but that was not the
giving of his life and so when we talk
about the blood of christ we mean the
life of christ he has poured out his
soul unto death as isaiah 53 tells us
and so the the blood of christ is the
life of christ lived in us you
understand to accept that victorious
life as mine through surrender to christ
that's how we overcome by the blood of
the lamb and by the word of the
testimony we have demonstrated that we
will be faithful to thus set the lord
regardless of external circumstances the
blood of the lamb
the sacrifice of christ which is the
life of christ given for us and our
faithfulness by his indwelling power
to god's standard of righteousness which
is his law because often the word
testimony refers to the law of god
amen amen what what a lot of us don't
understand obedience releases power
people ask me how do i keep the sabbath
by keeping it and that sounds funny but
an attempt to obey releases power a
genuine attempt to obey brings power to
obey you don't wait for power to obey
and when it comes then you obey in
obeying the power is released and a lot
of us do not understand that don't wait
for power start obeying and the power
work as you make a genuine attempt to
obey god because that power is god's
life himself or the life of christ
amen amen so elder screen i'm going to
move on to the last question that we
have here
alan white writes in last events
page 254 paragraph three
and i quote
it is often the case that trouble is
greater in anticipation than in reality
yes but this is not true of the crisis
before us
so
what are ways
god's people can practically prepare for
the time of trouble
simple
jesus told us
in luke 16 10
he that is faithful in that which is
least
is faithful also in much
if we're faithful to god now
excuse me
regarding the little challenges that
come our way day by day
we will develop the resources we'll
develop the power through christ to
handle the big ones that are coming
he that is faithful in that which is
least
is faithful also in much and he that is
unjust or unfaithful in release is
unfaithful and unjust also in much so
that's a fundamental principle be
faithful to god now in the little things
you will develop the immunity to handle
the large challenge to come the other
principle is matthew 16 24 i believe it
is what is the man profited if against
the whole world and loses in soul make
christ your priority
make the kingdom of god your priority
strip
secular things which are not all bad
strip them of the high position they
have held in your life and give that
honor to spiritual things
make that your priority my listening
friend that and being faithful in little
things
that will prepare you and me to handle
the terrible times
that are coming and they are coming at
first some people say well just before
probation closes i'll repent no no no no
no you won't have the capacity to repent
the time to get ready for the time of
trouble is now not when it comes
and so the two principles one be
faithful in little duties little things
the honor god honor guarded everything
to
make the kingdom of god
your priority it was for jesus it was
for his predecessor john the baptist it
was for the disciples it was for the
pioneers of this church it must be for
us
amen
so we can say something else
yes
make bible study a priority because the
deceptions that are coming will be so
overpowering without a clear grasp of
truth we will not detect truth from
error let me say that again make the
study of the word of god and the
practice of this word of unchallenged
priority for that alone will allow you
and me to detect the overpowering
deceptions that are coming upon us
amen there are abuse is good get it but
it will not protect you against error
are you following me high position
they're fine daniel had one joseph had
one nehemiah had one they do not defend
against error the only defense against
error is thus set the lord studied and
obeyed not just study for academic grade
studied as a way of life studies as a
source of sustaining power
amen
so there has to be that indwelling power
that comes from
god
there must be
you don't get drunk by smelling alcohol
you get drunk by taking it in
you become strong by taking christ in
keeping him ill through constant
obedience to his work
that's right that's right
this is serious business my good sister
this is a lot of christians are just
going to church once a week maybe not
even then and life as usual life as
usual is no preparation for the time
that is coming if you want to look at
the dangers of life as usual read luke
17 26 to 30 where the days of noah the
days of love that is eating and drinking
and marrying giving in barriers building
planting whatever that's life as life as
usual is no preparation for the time
that's coming upon us
amen solemn words that we have to take
in friends all of us
okay all of us
skeet we have covered the questions
pertaining to the remnant church
and we have about 20 minutes left to
cover the open forum that's fine all
right and i will start
i'll start with um one from aj he
submitted this let's pray first
yes father in heaven as we enter the
second phase grant us more wisdom and
insight and light in jesus name we pray
amen
amen okay so this question comes from aj
he's i also had a question pastor skeet
had mentioned in his sermon that we must
not cook on the sabbath i love cooking
especially cooking for others i used to
cook on sabbath afternoons and then go
to members of our church of our church's
homes
to drop it off some of them are seniors
and live on their own it was such a
blessing however after hearing this
sermon i stopped
and
all right let me just continue i stopped
i'm working every day from 7 30 to 9 30
often 12 to 14 hours every day except
sabbath
i tried to cook on sundays for others
but then ended up having no time left
for family chores and family and back to
work monday another pastor who knows my
schedule said what i was doing for
others
um
and it was good who knows who knows my
schedule and and what i was doing for
others said it was good i was doing good
on the sabbath could you please help me
with this or ask pastor skeet this
question on zoom with him i love
studying his word and want to do things
that please well studying his word
that's god's word and want to do things
that please him thank you
anything god asks you to do
he makes a way for you to do it
if god tells us and he tells us next to
16 we shouldn't cook on the sabbath day
we shouldn't do it
if this person feels that this is a
noble work and god makes an exception
the person ought to say to god father
make a way for me to provide this
service without violating your holy
commandment once you make an exception
of the commandment one or two or three
or four you've got to make it to seven
eight and nine
there are no exceptions when it comes to
obeying god you cannot make exceptions
for obedience because disobedience is
sin we're not to cook on the sabbath i'm
not saying we're harsh and we're made of
steel and we don't bend i'm simply
saying we choose to honor god above
everything else when christ had died he
died the ladies wanted to anoint his
body this is the body of the creator the
body of their savior they refused to do
it they saw where he was bearing they
went home and kept the sabbath according
to the commandment when the sabbath was
over then they came to appoint
the body of jesus let me say it again
they refuse to anoint the body of jesus
christ who was the one who said let
there be light who is the one who said i
am the resurrection and the life who is
the one who said i and my father are one
they would not anoint that body why
because it was the
south when god sees you determined to
obey him he will open the way for you to
do what it is you want to do so my
counsel is do everything to honor god
this may sound harsh above the hungry
even though god cares about the hungry
put god for and god will open the river
for you to provide that service which is
an excellent service by the way but send
me after this yes the bible tells us all
it makes it clear we should not cook on
sabbath it is only to warm it but we
should not cook on sabbath plain and
simple
cook on friday cook on thursday put it
in the refrigerator you have no
refrigerator leave it outside if god
kept it to the days of the israelites he
will keep it today because he has not
changed
but we must do everything
to honor god first the bible says he
that lovely father and mother more than
me is not worthy of me luke 10 37 we
must love god first put him first yes
this may sound harsh again we must put
him above the poor the whomever never
put him first
even though christ was found among them
we must put god first then god will show
us how to serve the poor how to serve
the homies how to serve the unemployed
without offending him
always look for a way to obey god always
look for way there has to be a way
amen amen thank you oleski
our next question comes from philippe
nicholas michelle
he says i understand based on the bible
and spirit of prophecy to not invest in
earthly things
like for example the stock market
so he would like to get from you some
biblical texts and counsels from spirit
of prophecy regarding earthly
investments so i guess it's like should
we be dabbling in you know investing in
stocks and so forth what does god tell
us about this
quite frankly i
i don't know
what i'll tell you is this christ said
let it out for yourselves treasure upon
earth where moth and rust does corrupt
and we thieves break through and steal
that doesn't mean you can't have a bank
account alawite tells us we should lay
aside something in case of a future
emergency so you make that very clear
and so i you have to make a personal
choice a personal decision but you must
avoid any activity any involvement that
lessens your effectiveness in the work
of god that takes away your time for the
work of god that's my guiding principle
does this interfere with my service to
god does this interfere with my
spiritual development will this so
preoccupy my mind that that's what i'm
thinking about and nothing else because
the bible says where your treasure is
they will your heart be also it applies
then it applies now and so the person
must take all these things into
consideration before making that
decision how would god be glorified if i
take this step that's a fundamental
principle how will god be glorified if i
take this step and if you can identify
how god will be glorified above you
then proceed but we must be careful that
we do not involve ourselves the things
of this world to the degree that we're
spiritually compromised that's the
general principle i will give but i
cannot tell someone don't have a bank
account don't invest i can't say that i
will say do nothing that will interfere
with your spiritual development that
will interfere with your effectiveness
as a proclaimer and a proponent of the
three angels messages
if it will make you less available to
god don't do it
amen amen
all right next question
this question says when the new
jerusalem descends from heaven where
will it rest that satan would want to
marshal the wicked ones to battle
against the saints
this in the descent isn't the mount of
olives that splits and the city comes
down it rests
there's a spot god will prepare for that
city
when the fires come the fires burn all
around the city
and satan and his horse will try to take
the city then the fire comes so god will
prepare a spot
where the city will arrest you city and
that's why satan and his hosts who are
resurrected will try to take when i say
resurrected satan doesn't die then he
dies in the fire but he's always been
alive the wicked dead are resurrected
and they join him and try to take the
city of course they fail revelation 20
verse 9 and 10 fire come down from
heaven and devour them and the devil is
destroyed in that same fire and the
false prophet and the beast and those of
course who worship the beast in his
image and so god will prepare a place
for god is the god of preparation he
prepared a tree to cover jonah when
jonah was complaining on that hill he
prepared a kingdom for the save he
prepared with hell fire for the loss god
is a god of preparation i go to prepare
a place for you he'll prepare for he
prepared a whale the bible says to
smaller jonah he'll prepare a spot where
the city will rest and that spot will
not be affected by the fire it will be
cleansed by the very fact the city sets
upon it the fire will burn all around
the city and will eventually burn all
the wicked and those of us who faithful
will be in the city looking out at that
destruction
don't be outside looking in
be inside looking up
and as much as it may sound like science
fiction it is a biblical reality which
is coming let me say it again it is
coming
all right
amen
all right so we're moving on swiftly our
next question comes from roshewski and i
saw rosheski was on
the question is what are the
abominations of ezekiel 9 and isaiah
chapter 66 verse 17.
um i know in ezekiel 9 we kind of did we
allude to that one where well anyway
where it talks about the ceiling of you
know setting a mark on god's people that
cry out for the abominations that are
done in the land
and i will read isaiah 66 verse 17
today forever jesus name amen amen the
word of the lord says they that sanctify
themselves and purify themselves in the
gardens behind one tree in the midst
eating swine's flesh and the abomination
and the mouse shall be consumed together
sith the lord for the abomination that
would refer to anything god has
forbidden as meat as as as food whether
it's a mouse an owl or snake it's it's
it the abomination that appears in the
midst of a few words like the the rat or
whatever else so abomination they would
probably refer to forbidden foods that
god will not have the israelites eat if
they'll obey him the worst abomination
in the bible is idolatry in other words
something replaces god that's the worst
abomination in the scriptures idolatry
which is the setting up of a different
god but in the passage recorded based
upon the surrounding word abomination
they refer to anything that god has
forbidden as food
based on that context
but the chief abomination in the
scriptures is idolatry setting up
someone or something to take the place
of god
what satan tried to do that's why he was
thrown out but there are several
abominations in scripture
a man with a man is abomination woman
with a woman abomination a human being
with an animal that's abomination but
abomination one is idolatry
because it replaces god completely
indeed indeed and i think that really
that uh
abomination in terms of idolatry is
really brought to light in ezekiel
chapter nine
and i'll read verse four for reference
the bible says and the lord said unto
him go through
the midst of the city through the midst
of jerusalem and set a mark upon the
foreheads of the men that sigh and that
cry for all the abominations that be
done in the midst
in ezekiel chapter 8 god just keeps
showing the the prophet just abomination
after abomination
order until at the very last we have
these i was it like 24 like 20 or 25 men
with their faces toward the east and
their backs toward you know god so
perhaps that could be about well at the
end of the day that's idolatry so yes it
is and
i hope that helps answer your question
roscheski
um
let's move on to the next one this comes
from brother carlington he says how many
prophecies are left to be fulfilled
besides the national sunday law
well we have the loud cry has to be
given
the full outpouring of the
the latter end when i see it full the
lantern is certainly falling on
individuals but the full outpouring on
god's people so they can work as a
people has not yet happened um we have
the uh the clause of probation has not
yet happened the little time of trouble
has not yet happened the great time of
trouble has not yet happened
um the death penalty has not yet
happened
the several last place have not yet
happened all these things have not yet
happened
but you're alive
today live for god today
you may not see these things happen at
all live for god today but all these
things have not yet happened but that
does not mean they are far off because
they have not happened something can
happen tomorrow so these things have not
yet happened according to the chronology
of prophetic events
amen and although this question was on
act someone sent me a message and wanted
to know if the vials or like the seven
trumpets that that sounded if those are
in the future or if those already came
to pass i believe those are the the
shofars that are sounded in revelation
chapter
uh
16. but from what my understanding is
they're incomplete fulfillments of
judgment whereas the seven last plagues
are complete would you be able to give
some clarity on that the seven last
plays are complete yes um the seven
trumpets they have begun to sound
they're referring to historical events
the seven seals also were opened in a
certain order referring to uh the
spiritual development of the church uh
the seven trumpets political social
events occurring
contemporary contemporaneously with the
development of the church so they are
they have been sounding and we still
have the seven the sixth and the seventh
the seventh trumpet the sound
because christ is coming under the
seventh
amen thank you elder skeet
all right so we are con we have some
more questions and the next two are
related to the sabbath the first is
after the sabbath seal is there another
seal no
that's right and then
that's it okay and now when you say
let me explain the same scene let me
comment on it
uh the sub of seal is really
you see god has
there's an invisible seal and there's a
visible seal what do i mean by that
when you totally surrender the life to
god that's internal you make a decision
it happens on here no one sees that how
am i to know you are totally surrendered
to god
the willingness to keep the sabbath
despite the death penalty
now this the outward expression of an
eternal condition are you following me
in the days of abraham they had a sign
it was circumcision but you couldn't
tell abraham was circumcised i mean the
man was fully clothed or any of the
other men you could not tell so that was
hidden but the outward life of strict
obedience to god's law genesis 26 verse
5 abraham kept my commandments my charge
my statutes my laws so the outward lie
is the representation of the fact that
in me i have made up my mind and i can
see that or people can see that by my
external behavior faith must have works
and so keeping up the sabbath is the
external evidence that inwardly i am
settled let me use the word settled in
the truth and nothing will move me you
want to kill me kill me i'm keeping god
self
so you can so the seal is on the inside
but it has an external expression
which is unflinching obedience
amen amen
thank you all the skeet and by virtue
you have answered the other question was
which was is there a sabbath seal
yes there is a sabbath seal
all right so we are moving on to the
next question and this one comes from i
believe shel dean altador and i saw was
putting some good comments in the chat
so
sheldon is asking for a friend in the
bible men were marrying younger women
are these councils against
or excuse me are there councils against
this if the woman is nine to ten years
old if the i guess that should be if the
man
is nine to ten years older than the
woman spirit of prophecy talks about a
disparity of age right
there uh
there are biblical and biological
reasons
why the man ideally should be older we
know a man in the 70s and 80s can father
child we know that a woman after i don't
know what the exact ages may be late 40s
early 50s can't do that and so
biologically it makes sense to have the
woman younger you understand because her
fertility expires much sooner than a
man's okay
secondly
this may sound insignificant but adam
was made first but he was older by a few
seconds or a few minutes he was made
first and so that makes the man slightly
older than the woman now ly gives us
great counsel and she suggests that the
man should be older the gap should not
be great i'm not sure if she gives a
precise age
as to the gap in the difference in ages
that depends on the general ages of the
couple for instance
um an 18 year old boy doesn't need a 26
year old girlfriend they're emotionally
different are you following they're
emotionally different now a 56 year old
man can have a 64 year old wife i mean
that's fine because you know in many
ways they're virtually the same and so
it depends on what is your age range if
you are 18 and a young lady why do you
have a boyfriend who's 37 it makes
absolutely no sense at all or a boy
who's 18 has a girlfriend who's 38 now
there's no law that says thou shalt not
do it but you know common sense is part
of the religion of god
and so
yes
ideally the man should be older
biologically he is he has a longer time
span in which to rep father children
this is not the case for the lady and i
speak with respect also biblically god
made adam first
and so there's a reason for that
and so he was a little old and not by
much we don't know how much time he
elapsed between adam's creation eaves
but he was made for a sea game first and
so generally speaking yes let the man be
older
uh i'm fred i'm no expert that women
mature emotionally more quicker than men
and so if
if you're 21 22 as a man
your girlfriend is 30 well maybe you
need a girlfriend who's 18.
but the general rule is the man is older
and don't have a great gap
but the older you get the less the gap
matters i mean an 80 year old man with
90 year old woman what's the difference
but a 17 year old boy with a 30 year old
woman we have a problem
there's a man asking me that question
uh please get a lady who's younger than
you insofar as it is possible
amen amen and you know i i've honestly
been seeing a lot of younger women like
in the church marrying men that are way
older than them and i've just wondered
about that as well because i i've read
some counsel upon that about ellen white
saying that you know within 10 years
really should be
the age range but i do have to you know
look back on that and really research it
right
son wcy he married a woman about 20
years or 21 years older than himself but
ella white loved her i mean she was part
of the wedding she approved
wholeheartedly and so sometimes ellen
white's counsel has to be read very
carefully within the context and the
time and the circumstances when it was
given because i think he remarried wc
white and a woman's about 20 years older
than he was and ellen white was
enthusiastic she loved it she approved a
blessing everything was hunky-dory and
so we have to read some of her counsel
carefully what were the circumstances
what was the context what was going on
when she wrote russia if you don't do
that we may misjudge ella white severely
and she doesn't need
that well thank you i did not know that
i got to do some research
all right so we have another question
and
this question is what is the best
subject to bring first to discuss with
my unbeliever friends in order to draw
them to christ the love of god
the love of god god doesn't love you
because you go to church he doesn't love
you because you're vegetarian or vegan
or your meat eater he loves you because
you're you and he has something in store
for you everything he has in store for
you is good he loves you wants to bless
you take care of you and give you
eternal life he just loves you as you
are and wants to make you better that's
my first message you cannot do better
than the love of god
you don't have to preach the sabbath and
ellen white and you know whatever else
eating drinking soy milk just talk about
the love of god
for that person personally right at that
time as you're talking with the person
there's a mighty being who loves you as
if no one else is alive and wants to do
everything good thing for you i've never
met someone who hates love never
or who is damaged by love
true love
it builds it restores
it resurrects
the love of god
amen amen now elder skeet i'm going to
make this
um
our
axis last two questions
this one comes from shirley van vict
surely what
shirley van vict it's the last name is
v-i-c-h-t
pastor skeet
i am taking my granddaughter to hike on
the sabbath to teach her about god's
creation during the week we are at our
different schools as i'm a principal of
an educator
is this wrong
it's not wrong sabbath is a good time to
tell your children about god as creator
but all during the week is a good time
to tell them that are you following me
adventists stress creation a lot when
they serve the sabbath and there's
nothing wrong with it but the high point
of creation was not trees the high point
of creation wasn't flowers it was the
creation of adam and eve are you
following me because trees were not made
in god's image flowers were not made the
sea was not made the fish was not made
in this image only adam and eve
consequently the high point should be
are we
how can i be more like my creator he
made me to be like him a tree doesn't
have to be christ-like you know the
river doesn't have to be christ's life
yes god made the tree i'm not against
that but we need to focus on what about
me
i was made in god's image let me forget
the tree for a minute what about me
am i living life christ wants me to live
am i reflecting his image and that can
be taught a little child yes talk about
the tree but let your your statements
center on
god wants you to be like him in your
little way
to go to me that tree whatever wants you
to be like him because the high point of
creation was the creation of humanity
not the creation of trees but god bless
all trees don't misunderstand me i love
trees i'm looking at trees right now out
of my window i love the water i got fish
i love animals i have birds i love birds
i wish i could fly but the high point of
creation was the creation of people
they were made in this image
not not trees and birds i like them but
christ didn't come to die for bird he
came to die for me
and so the high point of sabbath
observance should be father am i being
what you created need to be
i'm not ignoring creation physically no
they're lessons to be learned they
haven't declared the glory of god the
earth is full of his glory but
the focal point of creation was the
creation of individuals that they may
reflect on
amen amen thank you so much
god bless sister van victor little girl
i mean that little girl grow up to
reflect christ and have a place in
christ kingdom when he comes
and all of the little children listening
to this program
and god bless all the parents with
wisdom to raise them we are living in
difficult times
what a time to raise children um
amen amen indeed you know there's just
so much corruption in media
and it's just right at the fingertips of
our of our youth that's right that's
right
all right so we're coming down yes we're
coming down to a close this is the last
question but i just want to acknowledge
sister stacy anne who's been on and you
may not have seen her in the fore but
she's been behind the scenes capturing
all of your questions and sending them
directly to me as a message
so sister stacey
thank you so much she has to do a bible
program for the children so thank you so
much for joining sister stacy
this will be our last question from
rosheski again which is will the church
be purified
yes
unhesitatingly yes an impure church
cannot be taken to heaven it has to be
purified i mean of all impurities before
christ comes back um christ object
lessons based six nine paragraph one
when the character of christ shall be
perfectly reproduced in his people then
he will come to claim them as his own
yes the church must be purified from all
impurities and that's the church that
will be alive
in the last days when christ comes back
now those who died die moving towards
that goal of purification they are
covered by the righteous members of
christ element rise in faith workspace
50 paragraph one when it is in the heart
to obey god and efforts are made towards
that end god accepts this as our best
effort makes up for the deficiency with
his own divine merit the thief on the
cross didn't have a chance to live a
righteous holy life but he was covered
by the righteous jesus christ enoch had
a chance to do that either way both will
enter the kingdom of god sinless
the church must be purified
but not against its will we must
cooperate with the purifier which is
christ both he that sanctifieth and
those who are sanctified are all of one
how can you be one with christ and
you're a right sinner i am not one to be
one with christ is to be like him he's
not so much he like us even though he's
in human form but ultimately spiritually
it is to be like him he took our
condition that we might be like him
he lives a sinless life in our weak
nature that we might be like him that's
why he did not have any tendencies he
never practiced it
so yes the church has to be purified
it is god's will
first thessalonians 4 3 this is the will
of god even your sanctification is the
process of purification
but let me say this when you think of
the church think of you
not just to build think of you you are a
part of the church you must be purified
i must be purified this is not a group
thing so much it is a collection of
individuals you purify and god brings
them together
god did make adam and eve together he
made them separately i say that all the
time
mind captain personality volume 2 page 4
23 paragraph 2 the gospel deals with
individuals make sure that god is
purifying you
the church is fine but you are the
church let god purify you i hate to be
so emphatic but i had to
all right that's right that's right i
think that's the end but you know as you
were speaking i was thinking about what
we were also talking about before that
in order to preach the gospel we need to
be purified perpetually
you know it has you know we have to
allow the word of god really to be
metabolized in us so that we can be
ready for when he comes and be able to
even speak
for the truth because at the end of the
day we
we cannot bring out what has not been
put in and internalized
so it's it's a word that's a big word dr
mccrichen it must be metabolized tell us
what that means
needs to be broken down into its
smallest units and get some cells
exactly and i know you preach a message
on that all right if it's in the cell
you can't vomit it up it's there it
stays if it's in the stomach you can
bring it back up in the cell you cannot
bring it back up christ must reach the
cellular level
spiritually you can't regurgitate christ
when he's in the cells his righteousness
most of us have him in the stomach so we
vomit him when he doesn't give us what
we want he must be in the cells
nutrition that hasn't reached the cell
does you know good
it just comes out
anyway that was an aside
anything else
ah i think that is it i mean there is i
saw a question when you sent me the
email i saw a question that flesh and
blood will not inherit the kingdom of
god it was from several weeks ago i'd
like to address that and that's okay oh
yes let's do it let's do it let's pray
father in heaven as i try to answer this
question give me wisdom that you may be
glorified and your people enlightened in
jesus name we pray amen the
question was
how do you reconcile the fact that flesh
and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of
god and yet jesus christ was physical
when he rose flesh and blood will not
inherit the kingdom of god yes but flesh
and blood does not always mean sin it
can also mean corruptability in first
thessalonians 15th verse 15 but this i
say that flesh and blood shall not
inherit the kingdom of god but the last
part of that verse explained nor does
corruption inherit corruption what paul
is saying when we come from the grave
something will happen we will change
from flesh and learn meaning
corruptability susceptible to death
susceptible to decomposition susceptible
to decay that is what flesh and blood
means in in in that context and he goes
on to say behold i show you a mystery we
shall not all
asleep but we shall be changed in a
moment in the twinkling of an eye and
the last trump for the trump shall sound
and the dead shall be raised
incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptable must mosquito name
corruption corruptible means flesh and
blood incorruption means you're no
longer subject to death and so flesh and
blood shall not inherit the kingdom
simply means that
to enter his kingdom we must have the
body christ's heart now sin won't
inherit the kingdom either flesh and
blood may mean sin but if you read
philippians 3 20
for our conversation is in heaven for
whence also if you look for the savior
the lord jesus who shall change our vile
bodies that he might be fashioned like
unto his glorious body we have violent
glorious the word fire does not
necessarily mean sinful it means
corruptable because paul is addressing
the saints who will take us to heaven so
he says our vile bodies shall be changed
to his glorious body so vile flesh and
blood means susceptible to death and
decomposition
incorruptible is what we will have in
the new world so that's what fashion
blood means to not inherit the kingdom
of god but sin doesn't inherited either
i rattled through that but i hope
somebody understood something
amen it gives me an opportunity to say
study the bible contextually don't just
speak a verse and say here's what the
verse says study the verses after the
verses before the chapter before the
chapter after the entire book what was
the the the intent of the altar all of
that you've got to study to come to the
correct conclusion this is what the
bible says we do the bible this
injustice we do ellen white injustice by
not uh
interpreting her comprehensively
any other question
yes in fact this is from kevin prudhomme
elder skeet can you provide some more
bible text regarding the term bitter
herbs referring to oh yeah i saw that
bitter herb bitter herb first popsicles
in exodus 12
uh i think verse 7
where they were told they shall eat it
with unleavened bread roasted with fire
and with bitter herbs shall they eat it
so if god can't have you eating tobacco
and poisonous herbs bitter herb meat is
bigger to the taste not necessarily
unfit for food and the bitter herb would
remind you of the experiences they went
through and so bitter herbs uh
enters the bible as a component of the
passover meal
and the passover was the most
significant of the seven annual feast
this is the crucifixion this is the
sacrifice of christ so bitter earth is
not a reference to things we should not
eat it is an herb that is bitter yes but
it reminded the israelites of all that
they went through in the land of egypt
and also to get out
but tobacco is not a bitter herb in that
sense we're not to have anything to do
with tobacco not by taking it in
or selling it or buying it or
manufacturing it
nothing
if you work for the buckles factory or
company and you're in the advertising
department you know
don't work for a system that promotes
damage to health which is another way of
saying sin
god will find you another position
because he's god
anything else dr mccrichen
yes we do have some questions here
there's just one question i this one
comes from judah quite i'll pose it
perhaps you have it in your mind already
who is the uncountable people
um that paul saw apart from the one
hundred forty and four thousand
i it wasn't paul it was john
there we go uh john revelation seven
verse nine after this i looked and
behold a great multi-generational minded
number of all nations and kindreds and
people and stood before the throne and
before the lamb it's a great multitude
and 144 000. now some theologians say
it's the same thing i don't see how it
is the same thing 144 000 a select group
then there's a larger multitude and so
that's what john is seeing
because 144 000 are alive when christ
comes there's a vast muslim that's dead
the righteous dead they have to be
raised so we have two groups
we have two groups on monk
transfiguration with jesus elijah
represented those who never died
moses represent those who died on rose
and so we have two groups
but the same destination
amen amen amen
all right we do have another question
here from rodney smith and it says
yes will ephraim be saved
gleefully says
any individual who comes to christ will
be saved
in psalm
78 i believe it is
verse
67 68
moreover he refused the tabernacle of
joseph and chose not the tribe of
ephraim but chose the tribe of judah the
mountain which he loved the tabernacle
was once in shiloh which is in the
territory of ephraim and the tabernacle
meant everything to the israelites
everything and the philistines knew that
that's why they captured the ark and
hope the arts power would work for them
the ark was once placed at shiloh in the
territory of ephraim ephraim was not
faithful and after years of not doing
what god would have them to do even
though they're the most among the most
numerous of tribes and most influential
that's why the northern kingdom is small
ephraim the southern kingdom is called
judah ephraim is often used to refer the
entire northern kingdom made up of ten
tribes because of their faithfulness god
shifted the tabernacle from shiloh to
zion
you see which is in the land of judah
and so
ephraim i any individual ephraimite who
comes to god can be saved god saves
individuals when god pronounced when
noah pronounced the curse on canon the
son of ham eloise is clear
yes there was a curse but any individual
could have come to god when christ said
your house is left unto you desolate and
the hebrews the israelites as a nation
will reject it any individual islam
could come to god god will accept any
individual who comes to him
so yes ephraim i should be saying
dynaits will be saved
we may have some descendants of judas
will be saved we don't know
if you come to god
you'll be saved
so ephraimites will be saved that's my
best response
god doesn't save tribes he serves
individuals who are gathered together
that's right that's right god is a
personal god god is a personal god at
all times he never changes personal god
amen amen well elder skeet you know i
honestly can go we can go till probably
midnight with the amount of questions
that i that i have so i'm just going to
put a stop to it right here
as i said before i don't know how but
we're going to have to buy god's grace
pray and work out how we can answer all
of these questions
one more one more yes okay i have this
one open it says hello i am dennis
canike cincolio from kenya i'm a
seventh-day adventist
hello amen
someone wants to join the church um but
to know the true sabbath before he joins
he's i believe this should mean he's
taking me to the book of acts chapter 2
verse 46
and chapter 20 verse 7 and saying that
it's okay to rest at any day even the
first day
how can i approach that challenge
you simply point him to the fourth
command
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall now lay but let me pray
again father as i answer this critical
question on the sabbath give me simple
wisdom i pray in jesus name amen this is
the fourth commandment
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord
the sabbath is a personal possession of
god we need to understand that not the
first or the third or the fifth yes he
made them but the sabbath is a personal
possession of god it has a relationship
with him to him that the others do not
have as verily as the israelites had a
relationship to god no other nation had
and god says that over and over in the
bible
he god has never changed that
relationship so this friend of my
brother from kenya needs to he needs to
show his friend the sabbath is a
personal possession of god he calls it
my day isaiah 58 verse
13 if thou turn away thy fruit from the
sabbath from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day and call the sabbath and the
light the holy of lord honorable the
sabbath of the the holy of the lord
isaiah 15 13 12-13
it's gone today
this lord jesus christ is lord of the
sabbath
it is his
we need to understand tampering with the
sabbath is tampering with someone else's
property the same of this sabbath is
god's special day as that's why god told
pharaoh in exodus 5
if you do not let my first firstborn go
i will kill yours
you see israel special to me that's my
first born the egyptians that's your
firstborn the sabbath is god's firstborn
day if i can put it that way it is
special to him
it's not just any day like sunday
through friday it is special and he
calls it my day
hello my sabbath
well never read with god said you know
the second day since then the third day
says even though he made all of them
we're talking about relationship god has
a relationship with the seventh he does
not have with the other six days
as he had with israel he did not have
with the other nations but he loves the
whole world and so that friend needs to
be shown no no no no any day does not
work because god did not say any day he
said the seventh and god knows what he
wants
the seventh that's god's day
so in uh revelation 1 verse 10 john said
i was in the spirit on the lord's day
that's the seventh day there's no the
lord's day the seventh day
[Music]
next question
and may god bless that young man in
kenya as he tries to bring his friends
to the truth you know when bringing
people to christ praying sometimes is
more important than the argument we pray
a lot because god is not willing that
anyone should perish pray a lot and keep
the teachings simple
arguments don't convert people the
spirit does
next question
okay this one comes from aj again how do
we explain colossians two verses can we
get someone from someone who's not had a
question if you say aj again we've had
one from him can we get one from someone
else who has not asked the question all
right so this next one comes from sp i'm
asking for someone else
is it okay for a female to wear weave if
she is losing her hair
okay uh
where are we if she's losing her hair
loss of hair for male or female is
always undesirable but is catastrophic
for a female to lose her hair very very
damaging
i
uh what do i say to that
i can't find a text that says you can't
do it
and i cannot call to mind a quotation
from the spiritual prophecy that
condemns it
there's a fundamental principle in all
things the glory of god
if the person applies that and has a
clear conscience i have no authority to
tell that person don't wear a weave or
two weaves
um so if it's for the glory of god why
are you doing it
now
you know if someone has if i missing one
of my eyes i know without glasses to
keep you know the thing from being seen
and so
the lord is a very compassionate god he
understands our feelings he enters into
our feelings with us because he knows
we're flesh he knows that he's not hard
and stern and sometimes representing or
maybe i do that sometimes he's
understanding when a lot when he told go
to the mountain lot said let me go to
the city and god said okay
you know it wasn't the idea god said
okay and why i said oh how great the
mercy of god to his children god said go
to the mountain lord said let me go to
the city god say okay okay okay go but
god still loved him and god protected
him and so
if you know if i were a woman and i
would lose in my hair oh i'd find some
way to cover it up
look at men men do all sorts of things
to cover up their hair when they're
losing hair and so i don't see the sin
in it i just don't know if we're
entering something elaborate the size of
an eagle's nest now we have another
problem you understand what i'm trying
to say we have another problem things 10
feet long rolling all over the ground
i'm not talking about that i mean a
simple cosmetic intervention you know to
preserve your sense of self because how
we look affects our sense of self i have
no problem with that but i have no bible
verse four against it i have no egypti
quotations for against it but i would
not condemn it
thank you if i have a gap right here
something's missing i put in something
fill it out
are you sending me to hell for that no
no i'm not going
i don't see the sin i don't see the sin
so sister god bless you yeah i'm sorry
about the loss
and may god bless your efforts god can
restore hair he can if he wants to he
raised lazarus he can ris right here's
if he had a number pray to god change
your diet you know do something dietary
see what results you can get
next question
it's so elderski this next person would
like us to explain the difference
between mind
excusing between body mind spirit and
soul
okay
well there's even more but i'll just
pause right there yeah well
the soul can the soul freaking refers to
just a person
the soul can also mean you know your
emotional makeup your attitude if you
read uh numbers 21
verse 4
and they took the journey from an horror
by the way of the red sea i think the
compass the land of edom and the soul of
the people was much discouraged by the
way this they were tired they pressed
discouraged
emotionally the trip took their toll and
so the soul of the people it means not
your emotional structure it is you know
you this journey is taking too much out
of me but man became a living soul soul
is frequently a living being when god
sends the plagues in revelation 16 every
soul in the sea die means the fish so a
living being is a soul you have to study
contextually the mind that's the
intellectual capacity you see where we
make decisions that's in here
the soul can sometimes be the spiritual
part of a person we have to study
contextually so mind but all of this
makes up just one person a person has a
mind a person has an emotional structure
a person has you know a capacity to be
spiritual but we don't have three
different people when a person dies the
mind doesn't go north the soul self and
whatever is it's one person who has
components to that person
you know the heart has four chambers but
it's one height
and all chambers don't do exactly the
same thing
the upper does something different from
the lower but i'm not adopted i'll come
occurred to you so don't accuse me of my
practice all right next question
all right next question let me
and there's a verse that says don't
recall where the spirit of man is the
candle of the lord and that was your
attitude how do you behave do you rush
off do you fly off the handle how do you
handle segments the spirit of man is the
candle of the lord god's character can
shine through you just by your attitude
the spirit of man is the camel of the
lord your spirit some people say he has
a depressing spirit he has a joyful
spirit it doesn't mean there's a ghost
living in you it's just the way you
conduct yourself call the spirit
all right
all right thank you elder this next
question comes from may headley good
evening
i would like to learn more about
re-baptism
i was baptized 13 years ago since then i
have fallen and even turned away from
god all right but i have returned each
time and recommitted my life and since
then i have definitely grown and and
practicing being in his word daily that
i may have power to stand
i am now active in my church i would
like to know
if i am to be re-baptized i do not want
to miss out on the kingdom of glory what
are reasons that would call for
re-baptism
if i recall correctly you said she said
i i left god did she say that read the
beginning again i think she said she
left gone
yes yes even turned away i have fallen
and
the same way you came the first time
re-baptism is absolutely appropriate for
someone who fits that description
the apostle paul in acts 19 met 12
disciples who had been baptized under
the baptism of john
and he said have you ever heard of the
holy spirit and said we've never heard
of him john paul said what he taught
them then they were re-baptized i think
in verse
five or six seven acts 19. they were all
re-baptized evangelism page 375 when a
soul is truly reconverted let that soul
be re-baptized let him renew his
covenant with god and god will renew his
covenant with him reconversion must take
place in the churches and so based on
what i've read or what i've heard that
person should consider re-baptism yes
because you turned away from god now
you're coming back coming back does not
require a different root the same
original rule you need to be re-baptized
but go to god psalm 32 verse 8 i will
instruct thee and teach thee in the way
which thou shalt go let the lord convict
you but based on what you've said you
should be re-baptized
it's absolutely biblical
amen
there are a lot of people who need to be
re-baptized
they've walked with god so or they've
walked with the church but no growth i
mean 25 years 30 years have not grown an
inch they're the same people they were
at baptism as they are 30 years later
that person needs to start all over
start all over and get it right this
time with don't tell me
too many times we confuse church
membership with a relationship with
christ
more people are committed to the church
than they are to jesus
that's when the church treats them badly
they leave the church
but you don't leave jesus when you know
who jesus is and what he's done for you
commit to christ and someone who's been
committed to the church all these years
not to christ
really needs to be baptized
start all over again
amen sister sister kimberly peters is
putting in the chat that's right
amen
god bless you
all right dr mccurdy and anything else
there are a host more questions
more questions
pardon
now you said are there is there a host
oh no
i mean like there there are multiple
other questions yes
there are a host of questions left
uh and i i don't think we'd be able to
cover them no we won't today what's the
next question pick one and i'll answer
it
i'll try it out i'll pick one an easy
one
oh wow i just pressed on one and i don't
know if this is easy over steep but
it's well it's even two can the devil
manipulate our dreams
and
the second part is is it better to pray
silently or out loud because we know
that satan doesn't read our minds
well that's not too bad let's pray our
father in heaven as we continue to
answer questions speak through us i pray
please in jesus name amen
dreams are affected by what you see
during the day and by other other
components i imagine
i can't say yes or no i do know the
devil affects the mind he tries to play
on the mind and the minds cannot be
separated from
dreams so we have to be sure
that during the day our mind is resting
the right place
i have dreamt about things that i saw
earlier in the day that event affected
my dream or popped up in my dream it
really has i have dreamt about things i
was thinking about and then i dreamt
about it i'm not saying i can control my
dreams i'm simply saying how what we
allow into our minds can have an effect
on what pops up in the dream world
so i can't say the devil can directly
tell you what to dream or determine your
dreams or implant dreams into your head
but association with him can certainly
affect the quality of the dreams
so what i suggest to people is this
fill your minds with that which is
righteous all day
and the last thing at night on your mind
should be christ
our high calling i believe this is page
116 elle white writes your last thought
at night your first thought in the
morning should be of him of whom is
centered your hope of eternal life
so go to bed with christ on the mind
with this verse first john 3 8
for this purpose the son of god was
manifested that he might destroy the
works of the devil father whatever
citizen is trying to do now destroy it
just try it go to sleep with god as the
last thing on your mind because the fact
that you're sleeping doesn't mean the
devil is new
uh as for praying
as far as possible pray quietly as far
as possible so the devil doesn't know
what you're praying for or praying about
one of the reasons why i preach the
right priest i don't want the devil to
know what i'm going to say
so he can't go to someone's house and
keep that person from coming because he
knows i'm talking about the second
coming otherwise the devil looks over
the shoulder the preacher to see what
he's preparing and then goes and keeps
someone from coming she writes that so i
do everything up here so he cannot see
now he may guess when he sees what
chapters i'm looking at but he cannot
see exactly what i'm about to talk about
so he doesn't really know who to keep
away from the sermon
and so pray quietly is my recommendation
um but there's a time to pray out loud
sometimes i do pray out loud so he can
hear me
mm-hmm
did you hear me when jesus rebuked him
he didn't rebuke him quietly he breaks
him out loud
so there's a time to pray out loud but
most of the time every silently so the
devil does not know what you're saying
or what you're asking for whatever he
doesn't know
he doesn't know everything he can read
your face but he doesn't know
but so can your parents
so he doesn't know everything
all right next question
all right next question let me
choose another one
all right
i grew up in a christian home where
wearing pants as a lady is not allowed
when i was younger i did as i was as i
was told and did not question why we
were not allowed to wear pants
okay but
now i am a teenager
and i get asked why i do not wear pants
okay sometimes i honestly wish i could
wear them casually or casually
throughout during the week but not on
sabbath
my question is is it a sin for women to
wear trousers
i kept leaning because a coyote walked
past my window
and i don't see them very often so i
just i love to see god's feet just
stroll by as though he lives here anyway
that's why i was looking at him all
right
give me the question now should we wear
pants
is it yeah is it a sin for women to wear
trousers
i don't see how it is a sin i just don't
see how this is sin
um
there are trousers for women they
trousers for men
there are some parts of the world where
women wear what looks like trousers
and you go to india or other such
countries they wear a sort of pants
looking thing these trousers that we may
not call it trousers they may call it
something else is india but i it depends
on
what how it's made for whom it's made
trousers made for women don't look like
trousers made for men now we're talking
about these type type things that look
as if they were painted on by somebody
that's a different story altogether i'm
not talking about that that shows every
curve every line every piece of cell you
like i am not referring to that i'm
referring to something that does not
something loose fitting that that is
modest and to be really know what you
know what modesty is we need the
guidance of the spirit of god to
understand modesty but i don't see how
someone can say a pants is a sin
there are some places where men wear
skirts they look like skirts i was
preaching last night for a church in
fiji and the men of the pulpit had
skirts that's the culture that's what
they wear now i call it skirts kurt is
not the word i know that in scotland the
men were killed they look like skirts
but you can't put a kilt on me are you
following me that's not my culture and
so i can't say a pants is a sin i will
say modesty being properly covered when
adam and eve sinned they made aprons of
leaves they were partially covered when
god covered them he made coats there was
total coverage you see and so that's one
of the fundamental principles but not um
i can't say apparently to say no i can't
say that not at all i don't see where
the bible says i don't know why people
go to deuteronomy 22 verse 5. we don't
wear what prefers to put what pertains
to matter what pertains to a woman
and i'm perfectly fine with that
but uh a bodice you won't find me
wearing a bodice you can tell that
belongs a woman is not a shirt are you
following me about it do people still
use the word bodice
i have no idea what that is to be honest
okay
a bot is just like a shirt for a woman i
i guess i just dated myself uh when you
check the dictionary see what about b or
d i c e you know it's a woman's upper
upper upper garment
which uh i guess is equivalent to a
man's shirt
it looks it's a feminine garment you'll
never see a man in that unless well let
me know say that you won't see a man in
there and so i cannot say a pencil is a
sin no i can't say that at all
not at all
i've seen many pants they shouldn't wear
i'm seeing i've seen men in pants they
should not wear i'm very serious
and i've seen women in dresses they
should not wear
because modesty was out the window
the thing is the glory of god you see
that principle guides us if you truly
convert it the spirit of god will tell
you things not found in ellen white are
not expressively written in the bible
the spirit of god one of his functions
is to say no my daughter nor my son this
does not glorify god
i've said it before when you go to the
closet to pick a dress or suit
is this for the glory of god
and for what i've seen if people would
ask that question they would not wear 90
of the things they wear whether pants or
shirts or whatever they want to wear
them
because they know in their hearts this
is not for god's glory this is for me
mm-hmm i can't call panzer sin
i can call half nudity a sin
i can call it's part of your body
falling out i can call that a sin
you have this expression this world we
have under boobs and side boobs that's
where people dress
you see and no no no that's just that's
not modest
no no no no
next question that's not so
controversial
okay i'm well okay what is the
difference if someone is baptized in the
name of jesus or baptized in the name of
the father and of the son and of the
holy ghost
now jesus said
baptized name of the father the son the
holy ghost that's what jesus said
now the bible has degrees let me take
time on this what do i mean by the bible
has degrees who is the most powerful
angel in heaven gabriel he has more
power than any other angel
jesus had 12 disciples
three of them were close to him in the
other nine on several occasions he take
the three peter james and jump not to
the other nine because those three were
closer to him of those three john was
the closest and so he gave his mother to
john john chapter 19 26 27 when christ
was on the cross there are degrees
israel was closer to god than any other
nation the high priest could go where
the levite couldn't go degrees of
responsibility and privilege now
given that question again
what is the difference between being
baptized in the name of jesus did that
right right now jesus said
baptize the name of the father the son
of the holy ghost who in the bible has
more authority than jesus
is it paul
is it timothy someone explained that to
me who understands truth better than
jesus
christ when he was on the earth was man
he was still god
so when he said baptized name of the
father the son holy god what is my
justification for leaving that and go
say well paul said
when it was paul who when was christ who
called paul to preach the gospel now
i'll tell you something else
if you study the destruction of sodom
and gomorrah people only think of sodom
and gomorrah let's go to the book of
jude let's read verse six
jude verse six my first seven of the
book of jude verse seven of june let me
show you something
the book of jude
verse 7
let me know when you have it so we can
read it
okay
what does that say even as
even as sodom and gomorrah
[Music]
giving themselves over the fornication
and going after strange flesh in in
other words sodom and gomorrah are the
cities we use to express immorality but
the first since the other cities in like
manner but why does every bible writer
have to write
sonam gemara admiral savoy mandela let's
go find out what the cities were let's
go to genesis chapter 14.
i'm really glad for this question
because i've heard this before
genesis 14 we read from verse one
okay
you have it
yes i do and it came to pass in the days
of uh america king of china ariel king
of alessa kendall aroma king of elam and
title king of nations those of the
invading army that these made war with
bera king of sodom and with bursa king
of gomorrah china of king of admiral
shamivah king of the boy and the king of
baylor so we have admirals the boy
baylor solomon tomorrow we have five
cities those were the cities of the
plane but the bible almost always just
says sodom and gomorrah but when we
reach solomon tomorrow we must also
understand admiral
and de la but there is no need to write
all when jesus told the rich young ruler
in luke 18 he said what must i do to
enhance eternal life jesus said thou
knows the commandments don't commit
adultery but he does not quote him
why quarrel 10 just a few will tell you
he's referring to the ten commandments i
hope i'm getting through on this now we
know of the rebellion of korra death and
a pirate
they rebelled against more we know that
yes but if you read um
i think it's psalm 106.
i think it is 106 verse 17. both there
for me make sure i'm right psalm 106
verse 17.
okay
the earth
106 verse 17.
the earth opened and swallowed up
staffing
and covered the company of abraham who's
left off
there are three core ideas in the bible
but korra is a mention but
he is to be understood as part of that
group now let's go to the book of jude
read verse 11 the book of jude
and ran greedily after the era of balaam
for reward
and perished in the game
but we have to understand those three
now when paul says the baptized name of
jesus we must understand father and holy
spirit as well
but there's no need to keep messing all
the time but the fundamental principle
is jesus said father son holy ghost no
one has more authority than jesus christ
if your father tells you do this and
then your little brother who's five
years old tells you to do something else
to whom do you listen are you following
me
who has most authority in the bible
jesus
he said father son holy ghost why are
you bringing up you know what paul said
yeah i understand paul is inspired but
jesus himself is truth
paul himself isn't true
jesus is truth
he said father son holy god
i don't sorry for getting all work to
dress but some some things really get my
goat no well no not my god it's like
something else they really irritate me
and i have to restrain myself
there is no more authoritative person
than jesus
and he said father son holy ghost
why are you telling me that you know
paul citizen paul said that yes god
bless paul but paul got it paul was
called by jesus christ
this jesus said father son of holy ghost
that's how you baptize
let me calm down maybe no more questions
because i may just lose my mind
amen yes father have mercy on me
some things just get like dope they
really do
all right one more question then we're
done
one more okay so we'll make this the
final question
good day happy sabbath
i am a married woman
okay i'm reading the question okay i am
a married woman that is baptized in the
seventh-day adventist church and my
husband has betrayed me
and is in america and he has an outside
child as well as is involved in several
extramarital relationships
i would like to know if he divorces me
in order to get his paper straightened
will i be free from that marriage
contract can i
marry again to another man
thank you and please pray for me and my
children as i go through a hard time
dealing with the betrayal and acceptance
move forward with my life the answer is
she is absolutely free to remember yes
now god hates
separation divorce you name it malachi 2
16 the lord of israel he hates putting
away but he's given us provision the
condition is violation of the contract
yes she's absolutely free to remember
and the church recognizes that
short answer she's now i'm not promoting
that
calvary promotes reconciliation but
sometimes some situations are almost
beyond reconciliation reclamation or
redemption all i'm saying is biblically
she has the right to remarry and based
on our church's standards she has the
right to remember she's free
assuming she did not do what the husband
did
yes she's free free's a bird but
every effort should be made to fix
broken situations
romans 12 18 if it be possible as much
as life in you live peacefully with all
men
and if anything needs peace sometimes
there's a lot of marriages they have no
peace
as much as life in you what she must be
able to say is i have done everything i
could to save this thing and i failed i
have done everything i could you can say
that you're perfectly free even if you
don't say you're still free but god will
judge your heart that's what i'm saying
do everything you can to see
but you are free yes to marry if he dies
if he goes off and marries someone else
he is not free
he is not free but you are
because he is defending one defending
one must remain single all the days of
this our life
the innocent party generally
if reconciliation seems impossible
some people are so damaged emotionally
that is better for them to just separate
and we must not force on them you have
to stay we can't force that on people
because we don't know exactly what
they're feeling and the depth of
devastation we don't know
but the bible provides me yes this makes
you free
god is sorry it has to happen but you
can remarry
and if that's what you choose may the
lord grant you the happiness you didn't
have
i mean the lord saved that man because
god does not want to see anyone lost
all right here ends the lesson sister dr
donation
ah thank you so much elder skeet what a
time what a time did we have together
discussing the word of god
telling us a sweet time thank you so
much for your welcome
thank you i'll just keep may god
continue to bless you
your wife and entire family
and may the light of the lord continue
to shine upon you and may he renew or
even change your strength
okay so that you will continue to work
for the lord and i do pray and hope that
you also get some physical rest yes yes
i do i do my lovely sister i do thanks
for that and may god bless you all those
who work with you
uh in the work you do i i really i
really like this program that god has
placed on your heart
to start and make continue for a long
while and i hope those who tune in are
blessed i really bless enlightened
if i was a little hard sometimes forgive
me but sometimes
anyway may god bless all those who heard
it
and i want to encourage people study the
bible
many times i get questioned by email and
i'm quite sure the person has not really
made an effort and sometimes they say
have you studied this for yourself
bible study is fellowship with god
by not studying you miss time with god
personally
don't just say whether the text is
difficult try study it spend time ask
the spirit to open your mind compare
this verse with that verse look up a
particular word from genesis to
revelation it takes time but the
benefits are beyond calculation
make an effort to study for yourself
that's when you get the spiritual growth
when the spirit has spoken to you and
you have seen it and when god makes a
revelation i tell you my listening
friend you don't want to jump and shout
you can't sit still when the spirit
shows you something it's
it's an experience you must have you
don't get it by having someone else tell
you which has its place but when the
holy spirit shows you as a reward for
your effort to learn ah
it's a tremendous experience and you
must not miss it but it only comes when
we try to understand
and so thanks dr persian
for this privilege to be a part of this
very blessed program
god bless you and your studies
and may he use you to be a blessing to
others
thanks again
amen thank you so much elder skeet for
pronouncing that blessing i claim it and
receive it in jesus name all right okay
so you know since i'm doing thanks and
elder skeet we cannot thank you enough
for your time and for your presence
we say thank you we say thank you i'm i
extend special thanks to
also brother jonathan david archie for
asking the questions adding commentary
being here i know he's
very busy but he took time to be here i
thank god also and express things for
brother kevin gomez in advance for
ministering our meditation song
thank you brother gomez for taking this
time out to be with us and thank you in
advance karissa hunt for doing the
closing prayer
for all of you that are on right now
that have been asking questions putting
your comments in the chat thank you so
much for spending this time with us and
i really do pray that you are not only
blessed and enlightened but that we've
taken away some gems that we can apply
to our lives and share with others so
feel free to share this word the uh this
session has been live stream so it's up
on youtube it's up on facebook so you
can share this link with your loved ones
so that perhaps their questions would be
answered because we covered a lot of
open forum questions
i also express thanks to my mom thank
you mom for your support words of
counsel and wisdom and also to cousin
arrow who's on who always assists with
the technology and so forth and i
already said thank you to sister stacey
but thank you sister stacy and for also
moderating the chat and all of you that
are on i could name friends with son and
those of you that have been sharing the
word thank you for your time and your
presence and by god's grace we will meet
again december 25
um so-called christmas that's what's
being celebrated on that day by the
world december 25th at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time we are having a q
a by god's grace on babylon on babylon
so this sabbath we spoke about the
remnant church
next month the fourth sabbath god
willing will be speaking about babylon
so i'm going to turn it over to you
brother gomez to minister to us in song
and friends as you listen to the words
of the song just meditate on one with
the song of singing and two on things
that we've we we have learned today we
spoke especially about having a personal
indwelling practical relationship with
god letting the word really work upon
our hearts and upon our lives you know
allowing god to change us
so that we won't just be preaching the
gospel with our lips but we'll be
preaching with our lives so i pray that
that will be on our thoughts and our
minds as we go throughout
not only the rest of the sabbath day but
even our christian journey
so brother kevin gomez
all over
to you
thank you very much sister uh it's
always such a blessing to
learn from brother randy's kid because
we are learning about the word of god
and we know that the truth
make us free
and the truth of god can make us free
from sickness from
bad feelings and also
give us the hope of eternal life
and remember that is through jesus that
we can do all things
and it's because of his power of his
love or his gentleness that we're going
to be able to
extend
upcoming
trials tribulations
and for his power also we're able to
go through temptations and overcome in
the present as well so this one talks
about that is called gentle savior
[Music]
where are
the signs
which way should i go
i plan
each day
but now i don't know
tomorrow is a chance of uncertainty
[Music]
but i will go there
if you go with me
gentle save
yourself
[Music]
hold me close and keep me safe
me alone
[Music]
why can't
i walk
away from my regrets
and
wise forgiveness
[Music]
you say come with me
anymore
[Music]
my
hold me close and keep me safe
[Music]
like a trusting child will go
my
[Music]
gentle
shame
[Music]
um
praise god praise god gentle savior
lead me home thank you so much brother
gomez for
just outpouring your heart through that
song
may our prayer be that god our gentle
savior even jesus christ will lead
us home sister chrissa
please take us to the throne of grace
all righty thank you man let's borrow
heads
dear heavenly
wonderful father thank you lord so much
for this time that we had together
um communion with you fellowship in your
word
getting into your word and having our
burning questions answered we thank you
so much for your holy spirit that guides
us through these sessions
we thank you father for your love and
your care towards us the father
we pray for your help to love and obey
your word and to keep your commandments
we know that when we obey that we will
receive power from you
please make a way for us to obey you in
all things some things may look how we
sometimes we may be perplexed on how to
obey with a certain situation but the
father you are able to make a way please
make a way for us and help us to walk in
the way that you have made
if any idols that are in our lives that
are taking the place of you
we pray that you help us to turn away
from them
and help us to surrender to you
completely dead lord
thank you for the joy the power the
security
and the insurmountable blessings that we
receive through obedience
we pray for an outpouring of your holy
spirit and each of us each individual
listening in our families that we may
bear good fruit and be a witness for
jesus christ spreading the gospel
please continue to be with each
individual and family member represented
continue to guide us as we occupy and
work and school and ministry and in our
homes
we pray that you bless this this this
session and the ones to come so that it
could be a witness and it could share
your truth dear lord help us to stand
for your truth continue to prepare for
eternity bless each person listening
each household
everyone who has tuned in and who will
tuned in and we pray to meet again in
jesus name i pray amen
amen amen thank you so much sister
carissa and lord we say thank you to you
for making this possible thank you again
all of you that have tuned in
participated post your questions
um even share the message please feel
free to like share and subscribe as we
continue to take this message to all the
world but a hearty thank you to you all
and may the light of the lord continue
to shine upon you thank you all and god
bless